-Welcome to "Late Night."
How's everybody doing?
I just spent 12 hours
explaining to my parents
how to download Peacock,
so, yeah, I've been better.
President Trump posted a photo
yesterday of himself
and several Goya products
in the Oval Office.
Okay, but why are they
in their original packaging?
Are you trying to keep them
in mint condition?
They're kidney beans,
not a rocket-firing Boba Fett.
And look, I know he's trying to
encourage people to buy Goya,
but it looks like more like
one of those photos
where DEA agents pose with kilos
of cocaine they just seized.
Or who knows?
Maybe it's a local production of
"Glengarry Glen Ross."
"Second prize --
a week's supply of Goya.
Third prize is you're fired."
Looks like an episode of
racist "Iron Chef."
"Today's secret ingredient is:
Goya beans."
"I guess I could
make, uh, beans."
President Trump announced
yesterday that he has demoted
campaign manager Brad Parscale
and replaced him
with his deputy
campaign manager.
Though that one's on you, Trump.
You really thought he was going
to make you look good
when he made himself
look like that?
He looks like
a Civil War soldier
who was sent home
because of weak blood.
Infectious disease expert
Anthony Fauci said
in an interview yesterday that
despite the White House's effort
to discredit him, he has not
thought about resigning,
which is too bad
'cause there's another doctor
that is just
waiting for a chance.
"I don't know, man.
Have you -- Have you considered
putting on some 'Rick and Morty'
and just letting the virus
do its thing?
I'm a Rick guy. I'll admit it.
Rick gets me."
Hackers yesterday hijacked
the Twitter accounts
of several public figures,
including former
President Obama,
rapper Kanye West, and Microsoft
co-founder Bill Gates
as part of
a cryptocurrency scam.
Said Kanye,
"No, mine was actually me."
Rapper Kanye West's political
adviser said in a new interview
that West is no longer
trying to run for president.
As for what he's going to do
instead,
his political adviser
said to ask again later.
In a new interview, infectious
disease expert Dr. Anthony Fauci
said that he gets
700 e-mails a day.
Apparently, he once ordered
something from Crate & Barrel.
"And that's on me.
That was a --
I shouldn't have done that.
I'll take the full blame
for that."
A coronavirus vaccine
developed by a lab in the U.S.
is entering its final stage of
testing trials later this month.
And officials are hopeful
they could be botching
the rollout as early as January.
Music streaming service Spotify
announced today
that the Michelle Obama podcast
will debut later this month.
And as soon as
the transcriptions are ready,
so will the Melania Trump
podcast.
Authorities in Delaware are
investigating a recent robbery
at a local pizza shop
where the owner threw a pizza
at the robber in self-defense.
Added the delivery guy,
"So, yeah, that's, uh...
That's why it looks like that."
And finally,
according to a new report,
men should limit
their alcohol consumption
to one beverage a day.
So now I have
the other five at night.
That was the monologue.
Hope you enjoyed it.